qui n'a pas passé plusieurs minutes
parfois plusieurs heures au téléphone en
essayant d'avoir désespérément le
service d'assistance d'un fournisseur
d'accès à internet depuis quelques mois
les plaintes d'usagers ont littéralement
explosé notamment en raison du groupage
des services internet téléphone télé le
gouvernement devrait demander aux
opérateurs la gratuité du temps
d'attenté cet après midi et ce n'est pas
un conseil cela devrait devenir une
obligation à la fin de l'année il junca
un gie ce matin passé de longues minutes
au téléphone pour tenter de régler un
problème de connexion internet
c'est le lot commun de la plupart des
usagers des lignes à haut débit
difficultés lors de l'installation
coupure de ligne pour avoir une solution
il faut appeler une hotline le temps
d'attentes et facturer les abonnés sont
loin d'être satisfaits j'attends assez
longtemps qu'on veuille bien me donner
un
correspondant est il souvent d'ailleurs
je n'ai pas là la réponse à la question
que j'ai posée et quand on voit le prix
de
ses vaches que ses 34 ans qu'avec 34
centimes d'euro la minute c'est
exorbitant dans les chiffres le
confirment l'an dernier les plaintes des
usagers contre les opérateurs télécoms
ont explosé pourtant ces derniers ont
fait un effort sur le dossier de la
téléphonie mobile entre 2004 et 2005 le
nombre de litiges a diminué en revanche
les plaintes concernant l'internet haut
débit ont triplé le gouvernement a bien
tenté de mettre un peu d'ordre dans le
dossier pas suffisant selon les
associations de consommateurs dont nos
ministres de légiférer sur la les
publicités pour qu'elle devienne plus
loyale que les informations deviennent
plus loyal plus précise on lui demande
de légiférer sur la gratuité du temps
d'attenté
et on demande au ministre non seulement
de légiférer mais de doute de nous
donner un calendrier
ça fait maintenant huit mois qu'on est
en négociation le temps de la
négociation est terminé maintenant il
faut passer à l'action cet après-midi
opérateurs consommateurs et pouvoirs
publics remettre le dossier sur la table
une chose semble acquise la gratuité du
temps d'attenté sur les hotlines avant
fin 2006